when you first go into the airport there  are two conveyor belts where your  luggage goes in and if the luggage  appears to go through very quickly  compared to the UK and the ? we always  have in your mind is how is a guy when  it's being scanned on TV actually been  able to sensibly check all the luggage  that's gone through in the time that  you've had we've been a four or five  times not to his result but to other  results and it's all been fine no  worries whatsoever it is a bit of a  concern when you suck out you and not  knowing when you're going home but I  think when they do say on the flights  back up that it will be safe it clearly  will be so I don't think there'll be any  worries in that area at all